[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages
coming up we'll see what's making the
headlines with the sun's political
editor harry cole
and the editor of nottingham shirt live
natalie faye they'll be with us right
through until
midnight so let's see first of all what
is on the front pages
the metro offers free cheers to the news
that nightclubs are reopening
but also looks at the ramifications of
vaccine passports launching in the
autumn
according to the daily telegraph the
government hopes the launch of the
passport scheme will encourage young
people
to get a vaccine that also makes the
front page
of the times no jab means no
entry the headline the daily mail asks
whether the passports
are the price of freedom
amid worries too many people are being
pinged by the nhs
app the financial times carries boris
johnson's announcement
that key workers will soon be exempt
from self-isolation rules
the star suggests that the pinging
problem and the government running out
of lateral flow test kits on the first
day of
out of lockdown amounts to carry on
chaos
meanwhile the guardian reports on
concerns that governments could be using
spyware to survey political opponents
and journalists
after just such an accusation was made
against india's prime minister
narendra modi and the son has word of
prince harry's announcement that he is
writing a memoir
so let's talk more with harry and
natalie on what was freedom day
but is now if you look at the newspapers
uh new restrictions coming in
natalie um should should we be confused
by this or should we simply see it as a
way to encourage young people
to get jabbed well i think confusion is
one way to put it but probably most
people will be absolutely horrified at
the the chaos that's going on
uh no one knows which way to turn it was
supposed to be freedom day
but then you know a few hours after this
was announced and all those joyful
photos
you've seen of people in nightclubs
prime minister comes out and says no
actually we are going to do vaccine
passports despite
so many times over and over and over
saying no of course not
this is great britain we're not a papers
we're not carrying papers on you kind of
country
and suddenly we need vaccine passports
um i just don't think it's going to
encourage young people to get the
vaccine
in fact i think it could push
nightclubbing underground and we could
return to sort of 90s illegal rave kind
of scene
you know because i just don't think this
is this is the right way to encourage
the young people to get jobs
yeah interesting the daily mail leading
on this so to the telegraph
so to the times it it is it fair to say
it's left people slightly horrified
harry
i think as a small subsection of uh of
people a very vocal uh
subsection of people were very angry
about this so they'd be very angry about
lots of things
very angry about lockdown i think most
people will sort of shrug a little bit
actually
and think well i've had both my jabs but
then you know this isn't coming in this
isn't discriminating against like the
travel plans are in a way in a way which
means that
under 30s can't actually really go on a
holiday to ambulance countries this
summer
uh because without isolating well that
is very discriminatory
i think most people will just look at
this and think well let's see what let's
see what happens in september
when we get there this is so far away in
the in the grand scale of
sort of pandemic u-turns and ups and
downs and twists and plots that
frankly i you know let's believe it when
we see it um
i think what the government are doing is
they are looking they're looking at
france
very closely where president macron uh
announced that uh certain things so
you'll be
you'll need a vaccine double jab vaccine
passport to get into
certain things they had a million um a
million people sign up overnight
for for a jab however then they went a
bit far
a bit too far on that then uh they
looked at that result and then thought
well let's do it a bit further
and started throwing in restaurants and
bars and
all sorts of things and um people have
ended up on the streets
uh so there's a bit of a you know
there's a fine balance to be done here
but
evidence from israel does suggest that
there is a certain incentive uh led uh
vaccine
lure that you can get young people to it
but what i would just say
is i'm not quite sure we really have
you know there are 3 million under 30s
who haven't yet been jabbed
if we go back to january february i
imagine there was quite a similar number
of people who had been offered that at
the jab at that time who hadn't yet had
it
under 30s haven't really had that much
opportunity to get the jab yet so
i do think maybe it's a little bit of a
rush to judgment
yes that's true give them some time
certainly as you say
uh many not had the chance to get second
jabbed and france has
massively rode back already hasn't it on
some of its restrictions
reducing its fines by a by a huge margin
today after that reaction that you
talked about
uh what will the reaction be to the idea
of these vaccine passports coming in
we'll have to wait and see
uh your question i guess harry you put
is it going to be
a passport for a pint so you know what
is the difference
natalie between going to a nightclub and
a and a crowded bar
where you're allowed to actually go to
the bar now you know will it be a drip
drip i mean we've seen it across europe
this idea
will it will it come in do you think
come the autumn
well i mean as harry said you know so
many things have changed we'll just have
to wait until he's
seen till september and um he quite
brightly referenced what happened in
israel
um and unfortunately it wasn't really
adhered to
by the um you know the pubs and the
cafes and the nightclubs that were
supposed to be enforcing the rules
and so eventually it was dropped after
around three months and i think that is
something the government needs to think
about is
what are the nightclubs and those kind
of institutions going to think of all
the extra red tape that's now being put
on them
i know you know as an editor of a
regional paper myself we'll be going
straight to some of those
nightclubs and night economy workers
tomorrow morning or tomorrow afternoon
when they're up
to say well what does this mean for you
how are you going to be able to enforce
it
what's all the bureaucracy mean um do
you think it's
you're gonna have to have extra door
staff extra door security to enforce it
to tell a fake one from a real one
i mean there's all kinds of unanswered
questions we're in july supposed to be
happening in september
yeah well um the ft if we look at that
uh says the decision to open nightclubs
has made johnson's advisers nervous
right the way across the world we've
seen that nightclubs and events where
lots of people gather
indoors are a potential for super
spreading events this was
uh patrick uh valens the chief
scientific advisor
and certainly they're suggesting that
it's an attempt to pressurize
some 3 million as you pointed out harry
or 35 percent of 18 to 30 year olds
who have not received a vaccination to
do so people like david davis
criticizing saying it amounts to
coercing people into getting vaccinated
but their main stories about key sector
workers being exempt from isolation
rules
do we have any detail about when this
might come in because the list is quite
long isn't it
food water electricity medicines the
running of our trains the protection of
our borders and the defense of the realm
yes we had a bit of fun with this
earlier in the day when
dare i suggest this was a policy made up
on the hoof
uh but we it took a little while to get
some level of detail we haven't exactly
actually yet got a definitive list of
who's gonna be exempt because obviously
this the great pandemic um let freedom
ping as i think my favorite headline of
the day was
um you know it is blighting you know
various sectors not least the nhs not
least critical for supply
but there comes a point in you know how
many people do you exempt from this
before you make the entire policy
pointless obviously we learned at the
weekend that the
prime minister and the chancellor
believe that they should be exempt from
it
um but then you know how far down that
list of
critical infrastructure you go if you're
saying that the truckers and the meat
producers and the and the factories that
are producing food
are critical infrastructure what about
the people that are stacking the shelves
and manning the tills
it's you know it comes a point where you
have to draw quite a firm line which the
government tried to do
today the plan is to try to a little bit
and say look actually we're not going to
relax the app
that would be pointless we're not going
to relax the pandemic that would be
pointless
but you know where where do you draw the
line with this i think once you start
having some key sectors
allowed to be exempt in others others
not i think it just adds to this idea
that people are going to start ignoring
these orders
and they are you know we've already seen
millions delete the app in their droves
and using people's you know the problem
with you telling people to
practice personal responsibility is
often they will just take things into
their own hands um
and the results might not be the the
intended ones yeah indeed so
and they see people in nightclubs um and
they think why am i isolating for 10
days for something i feel like i've
probably not come into contact with
somebody who's got covered it
you know all of this starts to become a
balance doesn't it for your own
judgment um meantime uh the star
is focusing focusing on the decisions
being made by government um
not least what happened on saturday
obviously with the prime minister and
the chancellor whether or not
they decide to isolate because of coming
into contact with the health secretary
carry on chaos 1.7 million pinged into
isolation
iceland and pubs shot in staff crisis
government testing kits run out on day
one number 10 snub
solution of u-turn et cetera et cetera
um what what message just
should the should the public get from
all of this natalie
well i mean i think the daily stars hit
it hit the nail on the head there really
is it quite fun does with it splashes
nowadays i mean
they're quite funny but there's a
serious message underlying all of that
and obviously we're all familiar with
the carry on film so we get the joke but
um you know it's absolutely spot on
it is chaotic and i think you know
because we've got no proper opposition
at the moment
where is kia stamina and all of this and
the labour party what what are they
doing
how are they speaking up for you know
the people who voted for them last time
and the people who support them
um and meanwhile the government's just
sort of running riots
you turning at the slightest tweet
of somebody who doesn't like what
they're doing and uh being mocked on the
front of the daily star
so yeah i really like the front page it
just sums it all up perfectly i think
well sir chris thomas certainly put out
today how reckless he believed some of
the decisions are
um but does it matter but go on he's not
missing them no is he
that's the thing it's classic he goes oh
this is reckless then you ask him what
he's opposing and he says oh
we should give people more money to
self-isolate no let's stop freedom day
let's do that you know he's like well i
think we should
you know we should go a little bit
slower it's it's you know
it's ridiculous there is it is it is you
know
opposition by paint by numbers but just
it's just not there
yeah so my question to you um harry is
you know
should the government literally just let
it rip this idea that
if you if you step in now you are merely
postponing
inevitable cases is effectively the you
know if not now then when moment
and instead they've got a little bit
nervous and
you know it's either one thing or the
other what would you sense about what
they're really trying to do here
i i think i think there is a really fine
balance that needs to be to be to be
sort of the tightrope they're walking
and i think witty is the one uh
that sort of summed it up really well of
on the sort of if not now than when
sort of line of saying look this is the
middle of the summer this is when the
nhs is at its least
at its least pressure you know we can't
you know we can't
stay locked down forever at some point
there has to be this sort of you know
this balance made
and the problem is is that actually
obviously those those case numbers are
getting to as
i think he said you know scary numbers
but it's a sort of
hold your nerve keep looking at those
hospitalization
numbers we've talked about this many
times week after week
about that deal that was done to protect
the nhs it was to
stop the nhs being overwhelmed it's it
was never been it was never to stop
to eradicate covet that is impossible
you're never going to get to the zero
code despite the slightly loony fringes
of the left that want that want the
country to
and you know it's it's where does the
country sort of you know hold its nerve
what line do you get to what is an
acceptable amount of deaths every day
and i think we're about to find out
where the public think that is
okay it's going to be interesting in the
next few weeks a lot of uncertainty
as we heard from that news conference
today i'll keep an eye on that obviously
lots more still to come there including
harry has nabbed himself an exclusive
how the government plans to pay off
its massive social care bill it's that
hurry but we'll also have prince harry
news 2.
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now harry cole
and natalie fay welcome back to both of
you um so we're going straight to your
story
in the sun harry and this is about
national insurance contributions to fund
social care
what are you saying well we asked the
prime minister this afternoon actually
about whether he was still committed to
his 2019 manifesto promised not to raise
national insurance not all attacks
and he very very definitely avoided
answering the question and said
oh i know what he's all about this is
about social care and we'll tell you all
about that soon and
off he ran so ministers have been locked
in sort of
quite tense negotiations last few weeks
about how to fill
the social care black hole which is uh
you know
people have been for decades for a
long-term funding solution for social
care
brothers johnson when he arrived in
downing street in 2019 said i've got a
plan
and we're going to announce imminently
it's now two years there's the talk of
him
wanting to announce it on his
anniversary but of being
prime minister which is next weekend but
obviously he's now in isolation which is
sort of throwing that into chaos but
it looks it's the meat of the issue
which is there's going to be tax rises
the tories said they wouldn't touch
nationalists but the pandemic
black hole was sort of blown all out the
water and it looks like a salute they're
zeroing in now on a
compromise to not put up income tax but
to hammer
a penny on uh so one percent on to uh
onto national insurance contributions
now there's gonna be an almighty rat
about that because that hits the
youngest hardest
and you know they've already had a
pretty tough pandemic to now make them
pay for
you know a black hole that isn't
necessarily their fault or indeed
funding them yet
um is going to be a hard political sell
and just quickly who who would pay that
would it be employers
or employees then as it stands i think
it
is an employer's contribution there may
be an employee's contribution
it could be it could be one percent from
both of them which would more than fill
the black hole which uh
speculated tonight that that could also
go towards paying down some of the
uh waiting list costs and the and the
sort of black other wider
funding rules in the nhs which um might
make it a bit more of a palatable sell
to mps
okay watch this space certainly um
meanwhile natalie uh prince harry
daily telegraph a memoir in the offing
um
the word from prince charles was that he
is surprised according to one newspaper
yes i think um prince charles is
probably underplaying it there because
um you know i've heard that there's a
tsunami of fear washing through the
royal family about what's going to come
out in this book
um and i suppose the other thing to
think about is that prince harry
um said he wanted more private life um
i feel his life has been anything but
private since he's left the royal family
we've had netflix documentaries
we've had of course the open forum
interview um which was a tell-all
interview and now
a memoir which is reportedly been paid a
20 million dollar advance for
absolutely huge and um you know i do
feel sorry for the queen in all of this
and i think most people will do actually
because
she's not ha she's had an awful year
she's had an absolutely terrible time
her husband's died obviously it's
horrific and terrible for her and all
the rest of the royal family and now
this as well
you know i mean i think prince harry
should probably you know
give everyone a bit of a break in the
royal family it's not nice for them
okay natalie harry lovely to hear your
thoughts for now